in 20 seconds by giving another check  with his bishop instead he does  take that black knight yes he banks the  money as we say a monopoly so  yeah okay all you need to do now is stop  that black pawn and levon aronian is  going to win this game  and he has doing that okay so the bishop  has come back to give a check  and uh i think that pawn is definitely  in the eye line of those two bishops i  mean what's to stop the bishop from  retreating  block that pawn lock it with your bishop  just  and uh well magnus is doing what magnus  does best he is fighting hard because if  he manages to trade of  all the pawns and a set of bishops then  the position might be a draw  yeah so small chances for carson but  levon he's one bishop up now he should  not let this chance slip black's king  almost about to get checkmated anyway  magnus just resigns he resigns  wow what a dramatic final game between  these two  that means they tied the semi-final